the most important statistic in the
entire world right now is the inflation
number in the United States and we just
got it for the month of March the U.S
inflation rate is 8.5 year over year
it's the highest inflation in more than
40 years but 8.5 percent just isn't a
high number the underlying fundamentals
of this number are very very concerning
if we take a look here we can see that
the March number is the fastest monthly
inflation number of the pandemic era
since 2020. and if we go ahead and we
take a look here we can see that this is
the longest inflation surge in decades
and there is no stopping it if we go
ahead and we take a look around the
world how is the U.S inflation stacking
up against other countries maybe they're
all worse no the United States is only
better the Netherlands Spain Poland
Brazil Russia Argentina turkey and
Venezuela and if you actually look at
the real inflation rate in the United
States we are in bad bad shape so what
exactly is driving 8.5 percent CPA EI
well let's take a look at the individual
baskets and see how each one of these
goods or services is increasing in price
we can see gasoline is up 48
Meats fish eggs up 13
electricity up 11 food at home up 10
transportation of 7.7 and shelter up
five percent now the reason why this is
so crazy is if you think of the idea
that food at home is up 10 let me see
average American family is paying 10
percent more today to eat at home than
they were just a year ago there are not
many families who can withstand that for
a very long period of time but it's not
just food at home if we then go ahead
and we take a look at the shelter inside
of this inflation calculation it's
absolutely Bonkers as Charlie bulilo
says here shelters the single biggest
component of CPI it's 33 of the index
and it is only being estimated at five
percent year-over-year growth but but
the problem is that rents are up 17
and home prices are up 19 so how can
rent be up 17 and home prices up 19 but
the calculation of CPI says is only up
five I'm not a mathematician but those
numbers don't add up and so if shelters
actually up way more than five percent
maybe even in the teens that means that
inflation isn't 8.5 in America it's
likely in double digits so if we then
take a look Heather long points out here
perfectly inflation hit 8.5 percent the
highest since 1981. gas prices
accounting for a half of this Spike and
Rising food and rent prices also hurt
but wages the amount that people are
getting paid is only up 5.6 in the past
year and it is not keeping up with
inflation we can take a look here we can
see that the U.S average hourly earnings
is up plus 11.1 percent since February
of 2020 but the US real average hourly
earnings it's flat from February 20 to
March 22 and so regardless of what's
happening with inflation if people
aren't getting paid more at a faster
rate than the inflation they're getting
paid less in purchasing power terms that
means that not only is inflation hurting
them but they're actually not just
getting their savings eroded away
they're getting paid less on an hourly
or daily basis as well it's a big big
problem and so another question is how
long can the inflation go on can it go
on forever well this blue line here
shows from January of 1972 that's what
inflation did and this red line here
ladies and gentlemen that's showing from
January of 2020 big big problem and so
of course you can ask yourself why is
this happening and I know that the White
House the current Administration they
keep calling it The Putin price hike
that's just stupid what do I mean well
if we take a look at the inflation we
can see that the inflation has exploded
since January of 2021 one and see up
there in the top right way at the end
that's when Putin in Russia invaded
Ukraine I don't think that all that
growth in the inflation rate was due to
Putin in Russia maybe it's more due to
the current Administration and the
undisciplined monetary and fiscal
policies that they put in place it looks
pretty bad my greatest fear is that it's
only going to get worse make sure you
share this video with your friends we
need everyone in the world to understand
inflation eats your purchasing power
inflation hurts you you have to
understand this stuff you have to be
educated and you have to protect your
financial assets hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time